[Musique]
je suis en tout cas d'alpha tout comme
le nom de la gra parfumerie doro nommé
en série fate were à aller cette
parfumerie
c'est mon grand père qui l'a créé
d'ailleurs toute ma famille à travailler
mon père mes oncles mes cousins et moi
même j'ai grandi toute mon enfance avec
la patiente au parfum à l'ipp était
ville chargée de bello d'or celle de
l'ouvrier qui parfumait s'en rendent à
l'epp les bonnes odeurs de cuisine
syrien le jasmin delà de la maison de
mon grand père et quand j'avais 17 ans
mon rêve était d'intégrer l'école de
parfumerie de versailles
je voulais apporter à la parfumerie
familiale des savoirs théoriques en
chimie les savoir faire
mon grand père non loza nous les hans
ont nié mais la théorie
je voulais apprendre et comprendre les
procédés pour innover et créer de
nouvelles centaure malheureusement la
guerre a éclaté la guerre
de truites ou derrière elle la vie le
travail tout s'arrête
et pour venir ici en france c'est devenu
très difficile quand je quand j'ai fini
les études à l'ipp
il a fallu que je fasse un choix faire
mon service militaire de rejoindre cette
guerre folle ou parti en turquie pour la
fuir je suis parti en turquie en février
2014 où je suis resté un an et demi j'ai
quitté la turquie par le maire dans un
bateau pneumatique jusqu'à l'île grecque
de métier j'ai encore dans le nez le
dehors de caoutchouc mélangée à celle de
la mer je vais très fort
mon coïncide bien sûr mais j'avais très
peur je n'avais pas dit à ma famille
lors des départs je leur ai juste dit
que j'allais partie la turquie par la
mer je tenais ma famille cette nuit là
pour voter de 10 radio j'ai appelé tous
les membres de ma famille une dernière
fois au chaos
nous avons finalement attendre la côte
grecque
j'ai appelé ma famille pour leur dire
que j'avais survécu à l'étape la plus
difficile la mer ensuite je suis passé
par la grèce la macédoine la serbie
j'ai marché pour traverser les
frontières de serbie jusqu'à vient en
autriche
nous étions dans un camion en autriche
quand je suis arrivé j'étais avec deux
amis ils ont décidé d'aller en allemagne
moi mon rêve était en france j'ai dû
choisir continuer avec mes amis ou
continuer tout seul en france
c'était un choix difficile
mon objectif c'était plus important pour
moi je suis parti seul arrivé en france
j'ai commencé un nouveau voyage mais
c'est toi tout seul sans amis j'en ai
connaissais personne ici en france
j'ai tout de suite déposé a demandé si
je voulais que la france m'a reconnaisse
le statut de réfugié me protège m'a aidé
à mon logis de thibault on a été clair
avec moi un jeune homme célibataire et
en bonne santé pourrait bien rester dans
la rue j'étais bien
la dernière personne à qui on allait
proposée à 9 heures joie j'appelais le
50 chaque jour et on donne des la même
réponse pas de place appelés demain je
souffre et j'ai obtenu quelques nuits
d'hébergement
le reste des tombes g t d'or dormi dans
la rue c'est quelque chose d'horrible
on ne dort pas on est tout le temps sur
sega sans parler de the doors dégoût du
riz et d'humidité la raclette à côté
c'est cheryl d'un euro 5
la journée je restais à la bibliothèque
mais je ne parvenais pas à étudier n'y a
rien faire je pense est toujours temps
je vais faire pour dormir ce soir 2015
a été très dur j'ai perdu l'espoir
je t'ai épousée désespéré je n'aurais
jamais imaginé vivre ça l'année 2016 a
mieux commencé d'abord j'ai obtenu mon
statut de réfugié
j'ai rencontré des gens magnifiques
aussi court catholique dans des
associations comme giresse ou hilton
singer j'ai des amis qui m'ont hébergé
des personnes qui m'ont aidé ces
personnes là on tomber mes souffrances
avec le corps est pas qu avec les
oreilles j'ai aussi le droit de
m'inscrire à l'université j'ai commencé
les cours de français ont fait vriller
car jusque là
j'utilisais toujours l'onglet et enfin
mon français s'est amélioré tout un plus
que j'habitais avec des familles
françaises
c'est là m'a permis de comprendre la
société française je vais enfin le droit
de travailler
ça n'a pas été facile de tout mais j'ai
fini par trouver tous les matins je
suivais un cours de français et les
soirs
j'ai livré des pizzas en scooter vous
avez d'ailleurs peut-être déjà croisé la
4e manche c'était moi souvenez vous je
vous ai parlé de mon rêve intégrer
l'école de parfumerie de versailles au
mars dernier j'adore rombly le dossier
de candidature pour l'ofev au masters
j'ai expliqué mon rêve raconté mon
histoire mon expérience j'ai travaillé
tâche pied pour déposer un dossier
parfait j'ai 25 ans je viens d'aller g1
une naissance de chimie appliquée de
l'université d'alep
je pensais que c'était un bon
commencement pour attendre mon objectif
et pour être quelqu'un qui apporte sa
pierre à la société
malheureusement pour les codes et
versailles ça n'a pas marché
mon français n'était pas suffisant je
n'ai pas été acceptée ce refus a été un
choc pour moi une grande déception qui a
duré plusieurs jours
je n'avais plus d'énergie
je n'en pouvais plus tout ça pour ça
mais je ne pouvais pas abandonner ici
j'ai réussi à être admis en licence pro
de chimie en alternance à l'iut lyonnais
mais encore une fois ça n'a pas marché
malgré une centaine de cv envoyés
malgré des quelques entretiens je n'ai
pas trouvé l'entreprise pour mon
alternance ged ou encore bondi je viens
donc de commencer en septembre la
dernière année de licence générale en
chimie à l'université lyon 1
et bien sûr j'ai continué mes cours de
français mon rêve est toujours le même
je vais toujours intégrer une école de
parfumerie mai prochain
ces deux dernières années ont duré dix
ans pour moi mon chemin de vie jusqu'à
mes 25 ans ressemble un peu à ça
mais attention je suis pas triste
toute cette expérience m'a construit
j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai appris à
m'accrocher un bateau pneumatique à des
camions et surtout à mes rêves à garder
l'espoir quand tout s'écroule
il ne faut jamais oublier de rêver vous
allez voir un jour je serais né je serai
mais je serai un groupe afnor
j'ai même l'idée d'un parfum aux notes
de tête ou encore aquatiques comme nude
pouvons appeler mon passage en mer on
est d'accord
une fleur blanche comme le muguet qui
m'avait offert ainsi une des familles
d'accueil et nous devons le boisé pour
traduire la difficulté de ce chemin et
j'appellerai soparfin ml l'espoir en art
à merci
[Applaudissements]